hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over all
of these sorcerers or more or less all
of the humans of actual significance
that have died throughout the entire
jujutsu kaizen story so far to do this i
will explain the moments leading up to
all of their specific deaths in the best
chronological order that i can manage
which will hopefully give you a scale as
to how much of an increase in absolute
violence and brutality happens
throughout the later arcs in the story
or so far at least so obviously this
will include a plethora of different
deaths from throughout the manga so for
anyone who is an anime only this video
will have major spoilers for you so just
be aware of that also just before we get
into today's video are you ever browsing
their web trying to find figurines
straight from japan or even just
japanese products straight from our
physical homeland in general but can't
seem to find any sites who ship out of
the country well
everyone i've gotta sort it today's
sponsor for this video bae is absolutely
amazing bai is the largest proxy
shopping service in japan they place
orders or bids depending on the site on
behalf of the user who wants to purchase
or bid on those japanese shopping sites
they will then be collected and shipped
to the baii warehouse and from there it
is repaired so it can be sent
internationally to you guys so sites
like makari rakuten amazon japan and
more are now easily accessible through
baye.jp
what makes it even better as well though
is that through my link down below they
are giving everyone who signs up for the
first time 2 000 yen or around about 20
usd to spend on their site on your first
purchase which is literally like amazing
so make sure you go check out buy
through my link in the description to
receive that 2 000 yen off on your first
purchase but anyway enough of that let's
get into all of the sorcerer or human
deaths that have happened so far
throughout the juju kaizen story so here
is probably the most human and honestly
the most peaceful death that has
happened so far and in all technicality
it is the first death that happens
throughout yuji's story in the jujutsu
kaizen world and this here is the death
of itadore wasuke better known as yuji's
grandfather when yuji visits wasuke in
the hospital wasuke tries to attempt to
reveal something about yuji's parents to
him but usually refuses to listen or
hear what he has to say to him telling
him to stop acting cool but just before
passing away wasuke tells yuji that he
is a strong kid and to help people
whenever he can he goes on to tell yuji
to make sure to be surrounded by others
that love him at the time of his death
and not to turn out like him dine alone
in a hospital room he then passes away
leaving yuji with some of the most
influential words of the entire story so
far and words that yuji is determined to
live by but just after his battle with
yuta and the cursed spirit reeker a
critically wounded ghetto is forced to
retreat and he thinks about how he must
try and obtain rika next time so that he
can complete his goals but to his lament
give her encounters gojo and the two
start to chat ghetto returns yuta's
student id telling gojo that he was just
borrowing it the two then exchanged some
words and goku asks sketo if he has any
final words to which ghetto says that he
did not have any hate specifically
towards the people at jiu-jitsu high
it's just that no matter what he could
not seem to be happy in this world
gesso is then killed by gojo who decides
not to retrieve and bring his body back
to the school resulting in the birth of
suede gesso but that's another story
from another time
so the first death of the current jutsu
kaizen story involving yuji actually
happens off-screen and this is the
mother of june yoshihino nagai yoshino
instead of actually seeing how her death
happens it is stated in the document
that her corpse was found with its lower
half missing laid in their bedroom on
the bed with a bed sheet pulled up over
her and cold packs and ice bags all over
her lower missing body after nagai's
death her only son completely loses
himself and falls into the darkness that
both mohito and sugiru had been setting
up for him so that he could try and
manipulate itadori through junipei's
actions during a fight between yuji and
yunipe at the school yuji manages to
convince yunipei to calm down and join
jiu-jitec along with yuji and there they
will definitely find the person who
killed his mother however the small
moment of reconciliation is almost
instantly cut short as mojito appears
behind the two of them on the stairs
after mojito taunts the two yuji screams
for unipei to run away but juniper still
believing the facade he was shown stays
and tries to mediate the escalating
situation claiming that mojito was in
fact not a bad person however as he says
these words images of mojito's
experiments flash to his already
conflicted mind which causes yunipe's
voice to die in his throat as he
seemingly realizes that he's made a
grave mistake mojito places a hand on
the now shaken juniper's shoulder and
taunts him calling him an impulsive fool
who is no better than these so-called
stupid people he used to make fun of and
before juniper can even blink mojito
uses his idol transfiguration technique
and transforms unipe into one of his
many ex-human abominations yuji is so
shocked he's unable to react and just
stands there as he stands confused
the now transfigure pay gets a hittin on
him but usually ignores the pain and
instead focuses on trying to wake yunape
up
desperate and out of options he tries to
turn to secuna for help but is swiftly
denied and mocked by sukuna as well as
mojito
yuji now at a complete loss for words
can do nothing but watch as juniper
slowly falls to the ground grasping and
tearing at his clothes as he slumps to
the ground in death he manages one last
word
juniper
faintly asks
why
before collapsing completely onto the
ground
and dying after those two deaths we skip
forward to the gojo past arc and the
entire mishap that happens with rico
omanai who's best known as the star
plasma vessel while gosia was holding
off the anomaly toji foshiguro rico and
geto along with masato head towards the
term of the star so that they can
complete the ritual of merging the
tengen and rico once the three reach the
tomb of the star corridor rico and
masato have a tearful goodbye afterwards
riko and geto head further into the tomb
while leaving masato behind once the two
reach the main chamber of the tomb geto
gives riko the direction on where she
needs to head to find the tengen when
queso tells her that she can also leave
as he wouldn't stop her riku explains
how she was originally okay with mooji
with the tenkan but now she just wants
to be around everyone some more
ghetto tells rico that he will take her
away as that is what she has decided but
suddenly the sound of a gunshot rings
out and rico's body collapses in front
of ghetto with toji holding the gun
killing her in that instant
after toji kills rico he manages to beat
suguru comfortably and only spares him
because he wouldn't want to see the
destruction that would be caused through
all of the curses ghetto had caught
escaping upon his death toji then takes
rico's body to the time vessel
association base to be verified and
receive his payment toji and his
employer then leave after the
association transfers the money to their
accounts outside the association's base
toji is left shocked when he encounters
gojo who he thought he had killed just
before but gojo having literally evolved
in that moment had managed to learn
reverse curse technique to subsequently
heal himself and track down toji a
delirious and manic gojo explains how we
figured out the technique and how toji
almost killing him helped him master his
abilities toji takes gojo on but is
simply no match and becomes completely
overwhelmed while quickly analyzing
gojo's abilities to formulate a counter
plan toji is completely blindsided by a
hidden technique of the gojo clan by
combining gojo's two different abilities
into a completely new and unimaginably
destructive attack he creates the
notorious hollow purple
the attack fatally wounds tochi before
he can even think of a way to escape let
alone fight back
as he slowly dies goju asks if toji has
any last words and after some thor toji
tells his killer that megami his son
will be sold to the zenin family and to
do whatever he wanted with that
information which resulted in gojo
finding and looking over the young
megamie but after gochu and geso return
to jiu-jitsu high and get medical care
it is later revealed that again in a
similar way to juniper's mother's death
the last death of this arc technically
happens off-screen and we only get to
hear that while the best mates you and
nanami are out on a mission the two of
them got sadly duped they expected an
easy fight on this mission only to be
forced to retreat after the possible
grade one or even semi-special grade
curse spirit killed yuhaya bada after
the tragic death of yuhaibada we move
into the beginning of the most brutal
arc throughout the entire story so far
this is the shibuya incident arc before
everyone meets on october the 31st at
the shibuya station koichi better known
for the corpse he controls mikamaru is
in a meeting with suede gesu and the
cursed spirit mojito where it is
revealed that for the information that
muta was feeding the evil duo he will be
healed through the use of mojito's idol
transfiguration after mojito heals
koichi the two prepare to fight each
other as the fight progresses koichi
slowly loses the upper hand that he
thought he had at points throughout the
battle while stuck in mojito's domain
expansion koichi uses his simple domain
technique on mojito mojito's body
explodes and with it his domain
expansion disappears koichi then turns
his attention to ghetto and prepares to
start attacking him but mojito suddenly
breaks into the cockpit of his mega
mikamaru kokichi then tries to stab
mojito with his last simple domain
technique while mojito lunges at him but
sadly mahito ultimately overpowers
kakichi and brutally kills him i
honestly think it was such a horrible
death that the author decided to
completely off-screen the moment and
instead after the fight is over mkhimaru
is slumped over the dam which signifies
the tragic deaths of both kikichi and
mikamaru at the start of the shibuya
incident the next two deaths happen when
takuma eno gets into a battle against
ogami and her grandson ogami starts a
chant while her grandson protects her
from eno's barrage once she has done
chanting she uses her technique to
transform her grandson into a heavenly
gifted toji xenon using her science
technique once her grandson using the
strength of toji defeats eno she orders
him to go down and take care of the
other sorcerers when suddenly toji takes
control of her grandson ogami backs off
and wonders how toji was able to take
control since she only summoned the
body's information instead of the soul
itself while she stands confused toji
explains how he has a special body and
in that moment murders a terrified ogami
as for her grandson he subsequently died
the moment toji killed himself during
his battle against megami as that was
the only way to stop the rage that he
possessed
moving on after the battle against degon
that we spoke about earlier in the video
toji snatches megami away almost
instantly after defeating the cursed
spirit while this happens now beto's
attention is more focused on the arrival
of jogo who just made his way to the
scene joko manages to easily take care
of maki and an army quickly burning them
before they can even react naobiso
manages to evade joker's attack however
djoko manages to hit naobiso with two
disaster flames immobilizing the 26 head
of the zenin clan subsequently killing
him in that moment as well as naobito
ended up dying of his wounds off screen
at the end of the arc
after the death of naobito joko makes
his way to yuji where he finds nanako
and memiko have fed him a bunch of
sakuna's fingers as they are trying to
use sakuna to help them with the revival
of their former master ghetto
suddenly sakuna awakens nanaku and
mimiko bow their heads to the ground to
avoid sakuna's attack and sukuna tells
the girls to raise their heads and gives
them a smirk suddenly mimiko's head is
severed in a violent fashion displeased
sokuna asks if nanako thought she could
order him around for just a few fingers
nanako's sister's blood splatters all
over his face as she desperately calls
out to her in anguish desperate for
revenge nanako aims her cell phone
camera at sekuna and attempts to
activate her innate technique sakuna
activates his first though and slices
the top half of nanako's head clean off
he then follows this up by dismantling
her entire body into tiny cubes slicing
her into nothing but a gruesome spray of
blood continuing on with the complete
rampage that sakuna was on during the
time he was in control of yuji's body we
come to the battle of moharaga versus
sakuna with haruto's perspective where
he watches asakuna takes on maharaga
shigemo was left shocked that sakuna was
somehow able to defeat maharaga and
blankly just stares at zacuna sokuna
doesn't like how he looks at him though
and tells hirata to leave what yorata
does shikimo thinks that it's one of his
lucky days since he is able to live but
without even realizing accidentally runs
into sukuna's domain expansion and is
killed instantly being sliced into
pieces
once hirata dies it skips back indoors
to when an army had just fallen to the
ground after jogo had burned him along
with maki nanami somehow manages to get
up but is severely wounded and on the
brink of death but continues onwards
regardless when an army comes across a
large amount of mutated humans he thinks
about how he could have spent his time
living in malaysia as he begins to
become tired worried nanami thinks about
maki megami and naobito and wonders
what'll happen to them nanami then takes
on the mutated humans and is confronted
by no one other than mojito the two have
a small chat and an army wonders what
mohito's true intentions really are
suddenly he sees hayabada who points to
his rights nanami turns to see yushi as
mahiso places his hand on an army's
chest nanami tells yuji that he's got it
from here before his entire upper torso
explodes through mojito's manipulation
killing him instantly once the shibuya
arc finally comes to an end the
higher-ups try to pin everything on
masamichi for inciting the situation
between ghetto and satado that led to
the incident at this meeting they tasked
gakuganji were taking down masamichi
during the fight gakuganji manages to
facely wound yaga but then masamichi
begins to tell gakuganji a secret of his
related to cursed corpses
masameshi tells gokuganji that one can
replicate a soul's information from
physical information and that
information has to be placed into a
curse's corpse
three highly compatible cores that are
constantly observing each other must
then be placed into a corpse and only
then will the souls stabilize and give
rise to self-awareness three months are
then required for the cursed corpse to
reach self-sustaining cursed energy
kakuganji then asks masamichi why he
didn't reveal this information before he
was fatally wounded and masumishi
replies that this was a curse from him
to gakuganji panda then arrives and
gokuanji prepares to fight but panda
ignores him and rushes to masamichi's
side cradling the dead principal's body
at a similar time to the death of
masumichi maki had decided that she
would head to the zenon family household
to retrieve the weapons from the
family's armory sadly after she turns up
she is led into a trap where she finds
mai on the ground heavily wounded after
a battle breaks out between father and
daughter marky gets heavily wounded also
even having some of her intestines
exposed after oaky defeats maki he drags
the two sisters to a room used for
training against cursed spirits when
oaky leaves mai manages to stand up and
moves to maki where she senses a
heartbeat my comments on how tough maki
is before adding on how she suspected
that this would happen someday she then
leans down to maki and they both
transcend into a dreamlike state where
they find themselves at a beach mai says
that her injuries are too heavy for her
to survive what she is planning to do
and starts to walk away into the ocean
at first maki doesn't understand what
maya is doing so she calls out for her
sister mike explains that given they
were born twins their cursed potential
is tied to each other and for maki to
evolve mai will need to want to do the
same as long as mai who is not planning
to become stronger is alive and stagnant
maki will remain where she is too my
admits to maki that for her to grow mai
will have to die
mai then gives her life to create a
weapon for maki and remove her curse
energy completely allowing her to slay
the spirit and emerge thanks to her now
achieving the same superhuman physical
abilities of their cousin toji foshiguro
notices seeing the sudden disappearance
of the cursed spirit ogi then sees maki
emerge from the room upon seeing his
daughter ogie has immediately filled the
same dread that he felt from toji
earlier in his life he then draws his
sword and then activates his innate
technique to fight her once again but
she quickly slices his head in half and
kills him not even giving him a moment
to react
after maki dispatches her father chojiro
is with junichi and ranta after he uses
an innate technique to trap maki within
two rock hands however maki is easily
able to break out of the technique and
for a brief moment chojiro fights
alongside nobu akizenin however their
efforts were for naught as maki rips out
their throats and chojito was killed by
set attack along with nobuaki after
trojiro and nobuaki got eliminated ranta
uses his restraining technique on maki
seeing the younger sorcerer's struggle
junichi initially wanted to help him but
ranta insisted that they had to focus on
killing maki first junichi strikes at
maki with a barrage of gigantic punches
while ranta was holding her down but it
was to no avail and the older of the two
remaining sorcerers was beheaded moments
later
ranta at his deathbed due to the overuse
of his technique tells junichi he's done
it collapsing lifelessly thereafter
completely oblivious to maki walking
past him with junichi's severed head
once maki leaves naoya tries to crawl to
safety remarking to himself that she
didn't finish him off however marky's
mother who was also on the verge of
death walked up to naoya from behind and
stabbed him in the back at this point
naoya was too weak to use curse energy
to defend himself so he was killed
without even putting up a fight and
honestly for someone who joked that any
woman who can't walk three steps behind
a man should get stabbed in the back and
die i think this was an extremely
fitting death for the narcissistic neo
yesening so well that officially brings
us up to date with all of the current
sorcerer or more or less humans of
actual significance who have died
throughout the story so far at least
when it comes to nobara i've obviously
decided not to add her into this list
because well as far as we know it's
completely unconfirmed whether or not
nabarro is still alive or dead in all
honesty i'm assuming that she is
probably alive somewhere healing up or
at least you know that's kind of what i
hope is going on i've decided not to
include the rest of the cuckoo unit as
they really didn't play any kind of
significance in the story as they got
completely decimated and under a chapter
by maki if you think that i've somehow
missed any then be sure let me know in
the comments section below as like i'm
pretty sure like i'm like 100 sure that
i've got at least everyone of major
significance uh like in this video here
i think all of the other like remaining
human deaths were just unnamed civilians
also do be sure to go and check out baye
to get that 2000 yen or 20 off on your
first purchase through my link in the
description below plus hit that
subscribe button if you are nearing here
and also be sure to leave a like as well
as it really really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but anyway enough
of that for now it's been a professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]
you